well it's been a big deal for a few
years now and safe to say those young
adult novel movie adaptations they're
not going anywhere
just sit tight Maze Runner the Scorch
Trials so Maze Runner the Scorch Trials
picks up where the Maze Runner left off
Maze Runner in general I actually
enjoyed it as movie I hated the ending I
said that my review I said the ending
was [ __ ] then people were like well
don't worry you're being too hasty in
the next movie they will explain things
guess what I just saw the source trials
nothing was explained it's still
confusing as [ __ ] I don't see how this
world can even exist so I'm going to
talk about it in this review no spoilers
for Scorch Trials but yeah Maze Runner
later on we're gonna talk about how that
makes no sense all right so in this
movie the kids have been picked up
they're in this facility peter baelish
from Game of Thrones is in this movie
some people you just know when they're
in the movie you're like you're gonna
creep out you're gonna be an [ __ ] cuz
you're Petyr Baelish it's like you might
as well have Brad Dourif in this movie
so anyhow the kids escape this facility
and now they're going out there because
they need to find safe haven and
civilization maybe there's someone out
there who can help them all the while
the evil medical empire called wicked is
called wicked yes so you know they're
the bad guys
wicked so anyhow they're on the run
they're being pursued and this is what
this movie did Maze Runner was kind of
interesting because it's kind of Lord of
the Flies you don't really know what's
going on you don't know what's happening
but they had a neat structure too it's
not the most believable way possible but
they still did it and they had some
excitement when they went into the maze
now Scorch Trials is kind of this
generic ass movie where the future sucks
everything is a wasteland but the future
can only be saved by this youth not
saying we've seen that a lot but we have
seen that a lot it's not that exciting
you're not that interested you're still
springboarding off the last movie where
you're like I don't know how this world
can exist here is what pissed me off
about the ending of The Maze Runner and
here's why it still holds you in that
world where you're like no it doesn't
make any sense so an Maze Runner there
in this field and there's this maze big
biomechanical scorpions that kill people
and you're like I don't know how or why
they're there but hey I'm open to
suggestions then the movie tells you
that the world is now a scorched
wasteland and there's this virus out
there as big evil empire has the funding
to create this huge elaborate mechanical
maze pretty sure a world that looks like
this cannot produce something like that
it's like imagine the walking dead and
the munged is shitty
world that is the walking dead with the
select few people who are not actually
messed up in the head they can build a
Death Star I just didn't I don't get
that [ __ ] and why were they even in the
maze anyway why even put these kids down
there I'll be honest with you guys I'm a
little rusty on the information for the
end of Maze Runner because I kind of
tuned out the ending of that movie for
what I can tell these two movies have
been telling me ultimately there's a
virus in people and it's in their brains
the best conditions for studying this
virus or finding a cure whatever is
ultimately putting these kids under
extremely stressful life-and-death
situations while also making them
problem-solve that's kind of what I'm
getting but at that point why not just
dangle them over a sulfuric acid bath
with scorpions crawling over their
bodies while making them do a Rubik's
Cube or Sudoku or some [ __ ] be more
cost-effective than building that huge
[ __ ] maze so basically the maze is
overkill in every way possible I don't
know how they have the funding or
resources to even do the maze and
putting the kids in the maze is just
overkill so now you're left with that
feeling of this entire world is [ __ ]
so now you're in this [ __ ] world
where these kids are running along this
generic little adventure it was a pretty
cool scene where the main dude and this
girl are in the it looks like sewers in
there running through this big busted
down building and these zombie plant
people are chasing them that scene was
actually pretty intense I was biting my
nails I was like good job scene this is
actually getting to me then that seems
over you're like alright back to the
generic post-apocalyptic adventure and
that's exactly what you're in for after
that I know people are gonna be like
will you need to read the book no I
don't a movie adaptation of a book
should stand on its own to give the
viewer all the information they need you
shouldn't need to read the book to know
what's going on in the movie if that's
how the movie plays and the movie has
failed so these books may be great but
this movie it fails as an adaptation
that's on the movie plus if a saga or a
trilogy is going to withhold information
to a point where the entire thing
doesn't make sense it's gonna fail you
shouldn't do that it's a sweet to sour
ratio and here's what I mean every
question you raise and make someone go
hey that doesn't make any sense answer
two more questions because at this point
is four hours of a saga that doesn't
make any sense and I'm not really that
interested in seeing the third one at
this point that's how you lose your
audience so don't do that guys in the
end you walk out of the Scorch Trials
not really caring I feel like this is
going to be a case of if you read the
book you're going to be interested in
seeing the adaptation but it's wasted
potential if you're looking for a really
neat post-apocalyptic world there are
more interesting ones out there take
your picks course trials
interesting parts but more or less it's
a generic romp you're not going to
remember it in t-minus one day he
already forgot right so Maze Runner the
Scorch Trials have you seen it what did
you think about it or what's your
favorite post-apocalyptic saga will go
there whatever it is comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more